I think as a member with voting I do  feel a really great sense of  responsibility and and and being careful  in watching for but still I I'll respond  to the same thing that I've always  responded to in watching films with  which is hopefully it while I was  watching it did it did it make me forget  I was watching a movie did it make me  forget that this world is really not  real that I did it draw me in and what  was my gut reaction when it was over and  I think I've always looked for that in a  film you even as a kid but definitely  now when I when I watch movies and and  for voting especially uh just what was  my what was how did it affect me when it  was done